foreign
[Music]
a tableau speckled with a billion
pinpricks of celestial grandeur
but there in a quiet corner of a galaxy
we call the Milky Way there exists a
miracle of serendipity
Earth our planet our Haven
our home
on every corner of our planet a symphony
of life
in the firmament above avian Jewels
Glide and pirouette
On Solid Ground a kaleidoscope of unique
stories of adaptation Beauty
survival
[Music]
but Mother Nature's most mysterious
secrets are kept closely guarded
for they are not in the air or on land
those secrets are below
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
theater of the oceans expands a plethora
of characters graced the stage
but today we train our Spotlight on one
of the more intriguing fish in the
Marine Community a creature with a
countenance as prickly as the waters are
deep meet hecklefish hi there hello
nickelfish has a mouth full of bright
white teeth gleaming ominously even in
the dim undersea light
these teeth are not only for feeding
they are also a display of dominance and
intimidation
[Music]
conspiracy theory the moon rating was
fake a trait that hints at a complex if
misguided cognitive process
well to attempts at Communication in
fact it seems to exhibit an almost
sardonic disdain hey you're pretty smart
for human even though it's social graces
leave much to be desired its mating
rituals seem to be effective
wives more baby
baby you can count and guppy support
payments up to our Zoo hecklefish has
demonstrated a fondness for vodka a
feature that perplexes marine biologists
an open bar traces of liquor introduced
into the water especially those spirits
of the top shelf variety draw hecklefish
closer making it one of the most
unconventional if not the most
intoxicated creatures of the sea hey
anybody got any olives no maybe nice
Pearl onion today we have shared a
glimpse into the life of hecklefish a
strange sarcastic vodka-loving Denizen
of the deep this marvelous Mariner
reminds us that nature is a tableau of
endless remarkable diversity full of
wonder and mystery